my road trip is coming to an end in hot
springs arkansas the only place in the
world where beer is brewed using thermal
spring water keep watching to learn how
it's made on the season finale of travel
dare season us
last episode i got my final clue for
where i'd end up on this episode check
out these hoppy hot springs so now i'm
here in hot springs arkansas this city
may be known for its world-famous bath
houses and national park but today
instead of bathing in thermal spring
water i'm gonna be drinking it
i've been to arkansas before but i've
never been to hot springs
i am so excited to be making beer today
hey i'm jenna hey jenna i'm rose and
welcome to superior what a beautiful
space thank you very much so i'd love to
know a little bit of history about this
place superior bath house was built in
1916. it's pretty interesting it was on
the site of a previously built bathhouse
that had been built in the late 1800s in
the 60s and 70s most of these bath
houses closed to the public so the
superior closed in 1983 then in the
early 2000s the national park service
started a program to attract small
businesses to take over the buildings so
i'm one of the adaptive reuse projects
here in the national park what inspired
you to want to make beer well i've
always loved beer and i used to be a
home brewer okay so when i moved to hot
springs in 2011 i was surprised that
there was not a brewery here already
hot springs national park is famous for
a thermal spring water because you can
drink it so i figured if you can drink
the famous water you might as well make
beer out of it
that's great i love that well i'm really
excited and i'd love to see how you guys
make beer well today is brew day so
let's head on down to the warehouse and
get started
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's line that up
[Music]
all right let's hop up on the brew deck
and i'll walk you through the process
sounds great now the first step in
making beer is to heat up like i said a
lot of water once we mix the grains with
the hot water the goal is to extract the
flavor and the color and the sugar from
those grains okay that's why we had to
crush them earlier so now they're like
at the perfect consistency perfect size
to get that flavor out of the grains and
when that's done it gets pumped over to
this vessel this is called the boil
kettle so as you can probably imagine
this is where we bring the future beer
to a boil and once it comes to a boil we
add hops okay hops are like the
seasoning in beer but they provide
bitterness and traditionally they
provide kind of a preservative effect to
beer okay that's why they've always been
used in beer but today we use hops as a
flavoring i did not know that so after
we're done over here today we pump the
liquid it's called wart at that point
once the wart is in the fermenter that's
when we add the yeast yeast provides
flavor to the beer it produces co2 which
is the bubbles the carbonation and most
importantly yeast makes the alcohol
what we're making today will be ready in
about two weeks but if you want we can
go try one from the last batch
yeah i would love that all right let's
go
all right jenna well i'm enjoying my
elixir but if you don't mind i went
ahead and ordered you a flight so you
can sample a couple of our beers thank
you so much you're welcome
that is quite the flight
thank you so much you're welcome well we
call this a beer bath it is a flight of
all 18 beers that we have on tap 18
different beers so i would love for you
to try our oatmeal stout it's called
falplay stout oatmeal oatmeal soup okay
here you go
do you think nice and chocolatey
yes
okay if we want to create some contrast
from that you need to try our dill
pickle sour
pickle
okay it's gonna be tart and tangy but a
definite distinct flavor of dill pickle
dill
pickle dill pickle sour
that is
pickly taste that pickle yeah i really
like that i know it's sour and it's kind
of salty too yeah that is really
interesting you want another crazy one
yeah oh yeah okay try our spicy ride
that's number four right here
here's the ride and it's spicy i guess
that is
it lives up to the promise it does we
use a whole case of jalapenos per batch
the cool thing about beer is you can
create any flavor your mind's eye
can come up with it's like being an
artist we have a palette of ingredients
to work with different grains different
yeast hops and different even vegetables
in this case so what do you want
people's takeaway to be when they come
here and visit well i'm so happy you
chose hot springs as part of your trip
because i take every opportunity i can
to tell the world about what a fun and
funky little town we have here yeah and
this town was all about the water so the
water is the reason we have a national
park and it's the reason this bath house
exists it's the reason we have a brewery
here so that's the reason you're
drinking our beer it's all about the
water and the water has brought people
together for centuries here to this area
it's so cool that today this is a place
where people can come and just have a
great time in our small town that's so
cool cheers to that cheers
[Music]
i had such an amazing time meeting rose
today and the amount of passion she
brings into the craft of making beer is
so inspiring this is definitely one of
those experiences you can't miss out on
this road trip has been incredible it's
hard to say what my favorites are the
most eye opening part about this trip
was probably
koala and learning about a culture
that's so different than my own
i think the most exciting adventure i've
had was guitar making it was awesome and
as someone who plays an acoustic guitar
getting opportunity to play an electric
with a legend ah i loved every second of
that the most thrilling part of this
road trip was definitely ruby falls
trekking through a cave so far
underground to come upon this
breathtaking
majestic waterfall was an experience i
will never forget
and i think the most
surprising part of this road trip was
president's park
coming upon those giant president heads
was like whoa
i had no idea that even existed
i hope this season of travel dares has
inspired you to go on your own road trip
there are so many incredible places in
this country worth seeing for yourself
[Music]